hoping you're all able to both see my
presentation
and to hear me
is that correct
yes so we can see and hear your
presentation
all right fantastic well thank you all
so much for having me today it's great
to meet you
i am going to share with you today some
of the resources that we make available
at google cloud for researchers
um if you are a researcher you're an
undergrad or a phd student or a faculty
member and you
are conducting research with large
amounts of data you may be wondering how
the cloud can help you
and so i'm here to share some of the
resources you might want to check out as
you either begin or continue on that
journey and i'll take you through some
of what we what we can help
in your own cloud research work
so
um
i'll take you through an intro of me
brief intro uh share with you
some opportunities for learning and how
you might want to actually
build your own knowledge on what the
cloud can do for research
i'll then take you to
learning more about some credits we
offer
these are credits that can be
uh used to seed your cloud journey and
get started in the cloud without having
to open up your own wallet and then talk
through some of the communities we have
where researchers are meeting and
working together and talking about how
they're using cloud for their research
which might be helpful for you all
and then i'll make sure we have some
time for questions at the end
so i i work at google cloud i've been
here for almost three years um and a
large part of my role is focusing on how
we support researchers in their work
um so i've had the pleasure working with
a number of researchers over the past
few years
to help them use google cloud for their
research and i'm excited to share that
with you all today
feel free to contact me my email address
is here i'm an open book you're welcome
to email me with any questions if you
have questions after this session or if
you
want to know more about how to use
google cloud for research i'm happy to
to answer any any questions you have
so everything i'm going to share today
is publicly available resources um it's
all out there so what i would actually
ask you all to do i know this is a bit
non-traditional
is uh to actually open up this link in
the tab on your computer
or on your phone or however you're
watching this
because i want you to go check out this
page after we finish talking
so open up this link so you have it um
it's a thank you elia for putting that
in the chat um i know it's
non-traditional to tell people to look
at something else while you're
presenting but um i'll bring your
attention back now to the presentation
but i want you to have uh this available
and and be a resource uh whenever you
need it uh everything i'm gonna share
today can be found through this page so
keep it handy
before i go any further is it possible
for folks to share
in the chat and maybe the
uh the omixlogic folks can can read out
i'd love to just get a sense of who's in
the room um and so if you wouldn't mind
putting in the chat if you're an
undergraduate student or a graduate
student or a phd student or a faculty
member or an industry
coming from industry it would be
fantastic if you'd
share those in the chat
or you can share them
you might be able to share them with me
now that i'm presenter
i just want to get a sense of who's in
the room it will help me tailor
the the presentation a little bit
just give everybody a second okay great
i'm hearing seeing bioinformatics
graduate student
faculty member industry
masters in molecular and cell biology
teaching assistant professor
uh focusing on okay great so we have a
really great mix of folks in the room
thank you it's helpful for me to
understand that
um and i it elia's saying from youtube
there's under some undergraduate
students
great
awesome okay let's move along
so
first up let's talk a little bit about
learning
and i just want to make sure i can see
here what
you all are seeing
ah let's see
i think i can see that
all right let's keep going
so uh i
mentioned that we're we're going to
start by talking a little bit about
learning um and my my thinking here is
that there's probably a mix of
backgrounds in the room on
your level of google cloud knowledge or
understanding so
we know that academic researchers are
and researchers in general are facing a
world of constant change new tools
emerging all the time some of you on
this call might already use google cloud
for your research some of you may be new
to it um and so we we know that
researchers always don't always want to
spend a ton of time maybe doing the same
like training and certifications that an
i.t person would do um you have
different needs so
recently we've done a lot more tailoring
of our training offerings so that the
training is actually
very researcher specific and even domain
specific and i'll show you those in a
moment
um so we've created some new training
pathways and resources for researchers
specifically whether you're a researcher
who wants to build a genomics pipeline
or run a monte carlo simulation or
create an auto scaling hpc cluster with
slurm or host jupiter notebooks or
whether you've never heard of any of
those things and you're
you're
looking forward to learning
we have the training resources to help
you do that um so
uh moving into our google cloud skills
boost it's really our home page home
base for all training offerings at
google cloud you'll find everything you
need here um and students nit admins
actually get an additional bonus as well
as faculty members anybody out there can
have 3 30 sorry excuse me 30 free days
of access um to google cloud skills
boost and students and i.t admins get
additional credits and as well as
faculty members to distribute in their
courses
um and then i mentioned that we have
these very researcher specific training
paths i know this may be small and hard
to see
but the uh
the
the paths here are called out for
example if you are a genomics researcher
we recommend those training blocks on
the on the right hand column um on in
line with genomics so uh again you'll
find this all on that same page i had
you open up under the section for
researchers take a look at what's
available in your domain and see if
there's something that will help you
understand how google cloud may support
your research
for faculty who are looking to bring
google cloud into the classroom let's
say for your undergraduate students
we want to make it very easy for you to
teach uh teach google cloud uh to your
students so we've offered a free
curriculum for for faculty
you're able to
access this uh again on that same page i
asked you to pull up under faculty it's
a 10 module 40 hour curriculum you do
not have to do all of that if you want
to take one module to integrate into
your semester i encourage you to take a
look at this option so that you can
use these lesson plans and and use this
content um rather than having to come up
with it on your own um
and then one other thing i'll share this
isn't really learning but i wasn't sure
where to mention this in the in the uh
presentation i did want to share we
offer
guidance for people who are applying for
funding for cloud so you may have
had the experience of applying for
funding from the nih or the nsf for
cloud
and in particular the nsf has a process
called the supplementary document
and so we have this resource available
here i will pop this link in the chat
um
this is a resource
that you may want to bookmark
if you're planning to apply to funding
from the nsf anytime in the coming year
this will help you give you some of the
the basics on how you might
propose for
funding for cloud i'm happy to talk more
about that or provide more hands-on
support if you need it
and again you you have your email my
email uh let's see i put that in the
wrong
chat here we go all right there you have
it
all right so now let's say you've gone
through some of those learning
experiences and you're starting to feel
like okay cloud would be very useful for
my research i'd love to use it um
one way to get started is through
credits
we offer credits for for researchers and
also for classroom use
this isn't meant to be long-term funding
this is meant to help you get started
and seed your research on on google
cloud so
again using that same link i shared with
you if you go to the researchers section
you'll find
access for this um researchers are
actually eligible for up to five
thousand dollars in credits uh to use on
google cloud so the other credits i was
talking about were for our training
platform this is to actually build in
the cloud um
and uh it those applications are
reviewed on an ongoing basis there's no
deadline there's no time period you can
apply any time
um and you can uh apply for any topic
it's it's a topic agnostic
and then for classroom use if your
faculty member would like to teach cloud
to students
then there's also an opportunity to get
a smaller credit for
handout on a student basis let's say as
part of a google cloud computing
foundations course so
we want to make it accessible to get
started
and these are some of the resources we
have for that
so moving into communities we offer a
couple of different ways for researchers
to connect with one another we know that
researchers are often learning the most
from one another
far more than they can learn from from
anyone else
and so we have a couple of communities
that help people
connect on that level
um so the the two communities i'll
highlight here one is uh we have a
researcher community for anybody who
gets those research credits
um through google cloud that up to five
thousand dollar credit mark um they're
immediately added to a community in a
forum where people can ask advice from
one another um find out if there's uh
someone facing a problem that they've
faced
and get advice from their fellow
research peers about how they're using
google cloud so i highly recommend that
as an a way to connect with others and
with peers
we also have a research innovators
community and this is uh it's almost
folks who are are really active users
who are using google cloud quite a lot
for their work
we had a 2021 cohort and the
2022 cohort i believe was just uh
selected so we're not currently
accepting applications but again if you
go back to that link i gave at the
beginning and go to the reset
researchers section you can sign up to
be notified when applications do reopen
if that's something you think you'd be
interested in
it's really a tight-knit cohort they
work really closely together and there
are other opportunities for professional
development
and other benefits to be part of uh
presentations and conferences so it's a
great way to get additional
uh
opportunities out in the world um and as
part of that i'll just share two
examples from the the 2021 uh
research innovators cohort um which i
just i think it's always helpful to hear
examples of how people are actually
doing this
um
this first cohort 2021 had 33 google
cloud research innovators they were
across 30 institutions and eight
countries in both industry and academia
um and across all disciplines so uh
one example one of the research
innovators was dr tapio schneider who's
a senior research scientist at nasa's
jet propulsion lab um and his team has
this uh product called the climate
machine it leverages recent advances in
computational and data science to learn
directly from earth observations from
the space from space and the ground uh
and it helps harness huge amounts of
data
much larger quantities than them were
accessed before
to create create much better accuracy
for predictions of droughts and heat
waves and rainfall extremes so um he
shared his his learnings how he was
using cloud with this research
innovators group who also learned in
turn from him uh and then just one more
one more story to share with you
dr teodora sas who was also in the 2021
cohort
she's a computational scientist at the
university of chicago
she is actually using google cloud
solutions
to
identify and categorize images and
analyze images in children's books as a
way to understand uh what kinds of
representation children are getting
so she uses automl which has machine
learning capabilities that can identify
and categorize images um and they are
using that to understand how and what
kind of messages are our children
getting through books today um so really
interesting really broad range of topics
um really encourage uh taking a look at
at those communities if there would be
of interest to you
so i'll pause here um there are more
research more resources beyond what i've
shared today and if you keep digging
into that site i'm also happy to meet or
chat with anybody if you'd like to email
me again my my email address will pop it
here in the chat um
feel free to reach out to me and with
that i'll pause and take any questions
you might have about google cloud for
research
thank you very much alice that was a
great talk
all right
so some questions
uh first off do you have any advice for
those who want to get involved with
google or google cloud like are there
any qualifications that you say stand
above the rest
that's a great question i think um there
are there are homes for many different
types of people from so many different
types of background uh backgrounds and
experiences at google um i think my
advice is pursue what you're interested
in um and bring that interest and
passion to anything you interview for
whether that's at google or elsewhere um
and
i think uh if you're if you're
specifically asking about you know are
is there anything qualifications you're
looking for for research credits or
anything like that um for in terms of
our programs we have um
a
really broad range of research projects
that we accommodate through the google
cloud research credits um so there's
there's not a lot of of uh of
uh particular requirements i'll pop the
link for that
um and you can take a look it actually
lays out some of the eligibility
requirements so let me send that through
you guys can take a look
perfect thank you so much for that
um another question what kind of
resources do the cloud credits cover
so the cloud credits let's say you apply
through that link i just sent in the
chat and you are granted five thousand
dollars in research credits
um
you'll be able to use that on google
cloud console for any product that you
need so there's no limitations it's not
like you can only use it
for bigquery um you know or only use it
for one or another product it gives you
access to the suite of google cloud
platform
solutions great thank you
another question um can working
professionals try out google cloud and
get credits
so working professionals should go
through our traditional google cloud
free trial um and i'm gonna i can pull
up the link for that
um
there's a there is a free tier let me
pull that for you
um
the offering that i put in the chat
before
is really targeted at researchers and
and with the knowledge that researchers
um often may need a jump start in terms
of accessing cloud but those who are
working for professionals anybody can
get uh 300 in free credits to get
started and actually that will take you
pretty far that will be enough to help
you figure out if this is going to be
useful for you
uh and at that point you can figure out
okay how how will i uh be able to to use
this and is this something that i want
to pursue
great thank you um another question
which universities are now using google
cloud for genomics specifically if you
know
that's a great question i don't know off
the top of my head but you know uh two
other colleagues of mine are going to be
presenting uh from google cloud later on
in this
uh in this uh symposium and
um
my especially my colleague zeus will be
able to tell some really rich stories
from universities that are using
genomics he actually works much more
closely with customers and and helping
them access and use google cloud um but
one thing i will pull up for you
i know i'm sending you guys a lot of
links
um
if you give me just a second i'll share
with you a couple of different case
studies
um
from researchers it might take me a
second to get that together
and i also had a question in the chat
sent to me via direct message do you
allow training facilitators who run
bioinformatics events that train
researchers to apply for gcp credits for
those events
so
i think
right now the way that you can get
gcp credits to distribute is if you are
a faculty member or an i.t staff member
at a university or a researcher if
you're outside of that domain and you're
not actually working for a university um
you'll probably want to either access 30
free days of google cloud skills boost
or figure out um if there's uh
another way
to do that reach out to me and we can
figure out
via email
if there's a good way to help you um but
yeah typically the the resources i was
presenting today are typically
designated for university-affiliated
folks
great
well thank you again for speaking